frau wissler warum haben sie sich heute
enthalten im bundestag bei dieser
wichtigen abstimmung als es um die frage
der evakuierung die hinaus kabul in
afghanistan
wir wollten zwei botschaften senden die
eine ist wir sind dafür dass evakuiert
wird das so viel wie möglich menschen
gerettet werden und deswegen haben wir
nicht dagegen gestimmt wir haben aber
eine kritik daran wie das geschieht es
werden viel zu wenig menschen gerettet
dass es jetzt schon klar viele menschen
werden nicht mehr rauskommen die
bundesregierung hat die ortskräfte im
stich gelassen als sie abgezogen ist
ohne sich um die evakuierung zu kümmern
am ende juni gab es ja noch eine
abstimmung im bundestag wo nur die linke
und die grünen für die sofortige
evakuierung gestimmt haben und deswegen
haben wir gesagt grundsätzlich halten
wir das natürlich für richtig es müssten
menschen gerettet werden jetzt unter den
taliban leiden werden nämlich die
ortskräfte und ihre familien aber auch
menschenrechtsaktivisten
frauenrechtlerin aber und das muss man
ja auch sagen es ist eine nachträgliche
mandatierung es sieht ja so aus als sei
dieser einsatz vermutlich morgen schon
beendet das heißt das ist natürlich
jetzt auch eine bewertung dieses
einsatzes oder sagen wir leider hat die
bundesregierung ist versäumt alle
menschen herauszuholen die man hätte
dringend rausholen müssen und das liegt
daran dass man auf zeit gespielt hat und
es ein katastrophales versagen dieser
bundesregierung gibt wir erleben eine
fast zwei jahre krieg in afghanistan
und wenn man dann abzieht dann lässt man
die leute im stich die für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet haben und sie
lassen sie auch lustig indem sie sich
enthalten nein doch nein wir lassen die
bundeswehr lassen überhaupt nicht im
stich in dem wir uns enthalten sondern
wir sagen ja zur evakuierung und wir
kritisieren dass menschen nicht mehr
rauskommen werden für uns ist es
notwendig auch darüber zu reden wie wir
auch wenn die luftbrücke die
militärische luftfahrt endet wie wir
weiter menschen evakuieren einig wir
lassen die menschen im stich wir haben
ende juni im bundestag beantragt die
liste zur akuten alles
jedoch um die situation die jetzt freu
mich jetzt was machen wir ja dass
organisierte jetzt geht es darum diese
leute da rauszuholen und und sie sagen
wir enthalten uns im bundestag ist das
politische verantwortung die sie da
übernehmen
natürlich wie sage ja gerade wir sind
für die evakuierung wir kritisieren dass
der kreis der menschen die evakuiert
werden viel zu eng sie würden zum
beispiel in einen immer das beschluss
drin im text steht der signierte
personen das ist überhaupt nicht näher
definiert in der bundestagsdebatte ende
juni hat ein hat der redner von union
gesagt rochat menschen gerettet die
nicht die gefährdet sind sondern die
nachweislich durch die arbeit für die
deutsche bundesregierung gefährdet sind
das heißt also viele frauenrechtlerin
menschenrechtsaktivist werden überhaupt
nicht mit die werden überhaupt nicht mit
gerettet und das ist die kritik die wir
zum ausprobieren wollen aber noch mal
ganz deutlich die linke hat 20 jahre
gegen diesen einsatz gestört doch hier
haben nur zum bundestag enthalten weil
wir genau dieses signal setzen wollten
und natürlich hat die bundesregierung
nicht im vorfeld jetzt das gespräch mit
ihr gesucht und geschaut wie kann man
dieses mandat jetzt auch machen es ist
nachträgliche abstimmung letztlich eine
nachträgliche mandatierung und deswegen
wollten wir zum ausdruck bringen ja zur
evakuierung aber kritik an der art und
weise wie die bundesregierung sie
umsetzt und ich will nur sagen also ich
finde dass ausgerechnet der linken
vorzuwerfen bier würden leute im stich
lassen wir haben immer einen
abschiebestopp nach afghanistan
gefordert und wir haben immer gefordert
mehr menschen aus afghanistan
aufzunehmen klären und die
bundesregierung hat bisher zwar ausgeht
es geht
erst wofür jetzt
zum beispiel vernünftigen bleibe status
bekommen alles nicht das thema ich will
jetzt dass die festplatten gibt einen
kommentar von stefan reinecke die taz
die nicht im verdacht stehen die ersten
vorstandsvorsitzenden im fanclub der csu
zu sein stefan reinecke der schreibt die
linkspartei wird wie jemand der es immer
besser weiß und der während das haus in
flammen aufgeht erstmal einen
arbeitskreis zum brandschutzgründen will
hat er recht
neben ihm sitzt jemand erfährt er sagt
dieses abstimmungsverhalten schockiert
mich warum jetzt ist generell
schockierend nicht nur meiner meinung
nach wie sich jetzt hier die linke
enthält sondern dass hier in dieser
deutschen blase jetzt so getan wird als
ob man die menschen jedoch alle retten
will meine realität seit wochen seit
monaten ist eine andere ich stehe dort
kräften in kontakt die dort immer noch
festsitzen ich stehe mit menschen in
kontakt um hier auf einen fall ein
bisschen einzugehen und das auch bis ins
veranschaulichen eine orts kraft die
jahrelang mit der bundeswehr zusammen
gearbeitet hat und die noch vor zwei
monaten als ich und ein kollege eine e
mail anders aus wer sich aus an das
auswärtige amt geschrieben haben um
diesen menschen zu helfen um seine
familie zu evakuieren weil es bald zudem
kommen könnte was wir jetzt gerade
beobachten da kam die antwort nur
interessiert uns nicht weil diese person
hatte keinen direkten vertrag mit der
bundeswehr das waren sub contractor da
das sind so bürokratische kleinigkeiten
und floskeln das interessiert doch
niemanden in afghanistan jeder weiß dort
dass diese person und das ist nicht die
einzige person jahre lang mit der nato
zusammengearbeitet hat das war kein
dolmetscher der hat datenleitungen
verlegt wenn er das nicht gemacht hätte
könnten die soldaten nicht mehr
miteinander kommunizieren und das wissen
natürlich auch die feinde von solchen
menschen das wissen auch die taliban und
es ist einfach lächerlich dass hier
monatelang hat sich niemand dafür
interessiert und jetzt seit einer woche
ist ja das was frau wissen auch zu recht
kritisiert na ja das stimmt kommt man
später noch darauf trotzdem diese die
frage des abstimmungsverhaltens
vielleicht darf ich noch das
abstimmungsverhalten eigentlich ich hab
das auch heute erst mitbekommen und ich
frage mich hier natürlich schon also
mein aktueller stand ist dass die linke
und die afd sich enthalten haben falls
das nicht stimmt bitte korrigieren sie
mich aber
ich denke dass diese zwei parteien jetzt
aber auch alle anderen parteien einfach
auf kosten afghanischer menschenleben
wird politik machen und dass man hier
wieder den wahlkampf im auge behält und
dass man und das ist die größte sorge
hier und das erfahre ich auch in den
letzten tagen wurde ich von
interviewanfragen überhäuft und das hat
mich auch wirklich irgendwann einfach
aufgeregt wenn das heißt komm jetzt die
nächsten flüchtlinge 2015 wiederholt
sich das heißt jeder werden wir auch
gleich darüber werden sie ist auch so
ein satz der gerade sehr fokussiert ist
so herr alexander wir gerade sagt dass
da sozusagen auf kosten von orts kräften
von mitarbeitern der bundeswehr der nato
politik gemacht wird und ich will das
nicht bewerten
erst mal beschreiben weil was bislang
gesagt hat die linke hätte sich
enthalten stimmt überhaupt nicht die
linke hatte heute im bundestag alle drei
positionen im angebot das haben
linke-abgeordnete zugestimmt dass haben
sich liga abonnenten 52 700 haben der
letzte abgeordnete das abgelehnt es
haben auch linke-abgeordnete plakate
gepostet auf facebook die die grünen und
die anderen parteien die zugestimmt
haben als kriegstreiber bestimmt haben
die linken die zugestimmt haben haben
uns in die redaktion briefe geschrieben
und ihrem gewissen begründet warum sie
von ihrer fraktion abweichen das ist
doch jetzt wirklich eine ganz
entscheidende frage ob man diese
menschen herausholt und da hat die
fraktion alle drei möglichen meinungen
im angebot das ist absolut abenteuerlich
und dass sie sich enthalten haben ist
auch erst in einer umkämpften
fraktionssitzung zustande gekommen die
genauso gut hätte anders ausgehen können
das konnte ihm auch der größte
linkspartei expertin nicht vorhersagen
also sie haben dazu keine sortierte
meinung in so einer frage wo es um leben
und tod von after angeht aber wenn es
dumm läuft auch von bundeswehrsoldaten
und das ist wirklich jetzt wünsche ich
doch in die bewertung weil ich das ist
einfach ich finde das kann dann hört wie
wir haben sie denn abgestimmt hobbys
lacht das ist irgendwie keine
bundestagsabgeordnete wir hätten sicher
noch zustimmen das stimmt wie hätten sie
den lack bestreite ich habe ich habe
dafür argumentiert dass wir uns
enthalten und ich will das noch mal
deutlich machen dass wir es doch gesagt
dass wir uns das nicht leicht gemacht
haben sondern dass wir die frage
diskutiert haben dass wir darüber darum
gerungen haben wie wir abstimmen und
dass ich auch alles dass ich das
natürlich auch nachvollziehen kann dass
bildung genossen auch gesagt haben ich
stimme dazu dass genossen und gesagt
haben jetzt nach so viel jahren
kriegseinsatz jetzt wieder ein robustes
man also die linke hat sich mehrheitlich
enthalten weil ganz klar wie zum
ausdruck bringen wollten die
bundesregierung lässt dort menschen im
stich und jetzt wo dieser
einsatz ebenso gut wie beendet ist so
sagen das war gut und das war prima das
ist ein problem weil die menschen ich
wenn wir mehr haben ja selber auch die
hilferufe wir haben so viele menschen
die wir gemeldet haben ans auswärtige
amt an den krisenstab der verzweiflung
wir sollten dann raucht es ist gar nicht
die kritik dass die bundeswehr sie
herausholt das doch gar nicht unsere
kritik was ist denn dann genau wie ich
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz vor aus der
abstimmungsempfehlung ihrer partei
sollte das mandat wie bislang eine
evakuierung fast nur für deutsche
vorsehen und wenn nicht ausgeschlossen
wird dass sich die bundeswehr den weg
durch kabul erst frei schießen muss dann
kommt nun die enthaltung in betracht
wer soll es dann machen ja also das
erste ist ganz klar der kreis der
menschen die gerettet werden den wollen
wir ausweiten wir haben die situation
erlebt das orts kreis hat doch niemand
behauptet dass nur deutsche herausgeholt
werden dass ortskräfte gesagt wurde ihr
werdet ausgeflogen aber eure erwachsenen
söhne müssen dem land wir haben mit
menschen gesprochen die vor zehn jahren
für die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben und
denen erklärt wurde dass sie nicht auf
den listen stehen wir erleben gerade
dass die gez
bleibeprämien bezahlt also menschen geld
anbietet den jahresgehalt anbietet wenn
sie sich verpflichten dass sie sich
nicht retten lassen das halten wir für
wirklich das halte ich für skandalös
bestritt umgeben dass sie ihr leben
riskieren und deswegen allen die an
zustimmung in der wir haben dem
afghanistan-mandat immer wir haben es
immer abgelehnt heute im bundestag haben
wir uns mehrheitlich enthalten und das
war auch die klare empfehlung der partei
weil wir nicht gegen die evakuierung
sind natürlich sind wenn das nicht aber
das problem ist doch dass die
bundesregierung so viel zeit verloren
hat dass man über monate hinweg das
gesamte militärische gerät ausgeflogen
hat die soldaten ausgeflogen hat aber
die menschen die dort sonst nicht das
thema sind natürlich ist dass das thema
das ich jetzt nicht gerade
dieses wasser oder heute doch nicht
jetzt doch nicht vom himmel gefallen
sondern dass es doch die freude von 20
jahren kriegspolitik davon also sich den
toten ist richtig die geschichte beginnt
ja nicht erst vor drei wochen aber da
nein da wo er heute nicht abgestimmt
frau wisla einst ist man bitte nach aber
es immer was wir heute abgestimmt haben
habe ich jetzt mehrfach deutlich gesagt
ja wir sind für die evakuierung so viele
möglich menschen retten wir halten das
bürokratische herangehen der
bundesregierung die eingrenzung des
kreises von menschen die überhaupt
gerettet werden das bundeswehr flieger
nicht voll staaten und menschen am
flughafen zum teil abgewiesen werden das
halten wir für ein riesiges problem
dieser rettungseinsatz wird morgen
beendet sein das heißt viele menschen
kommen doch gar nicht mehr raus merkel
18.000 menschen mussten evakuiert werden
jetzt sind es nicht mal die hälfte oder
vielleicht sind das jetzt gerade die
hälfte jetzt nach dem letzten flieger
und das ist unsere kritik daran aber wir
blockieren hast auch nicht mehr stimmt
auch nicht dagegen wir sagen ja nicht
wir sind dagegen sondern wir wollen
unsere kritik zum ausdruck geben und
verrühren wenn es auf uns an kehre die
das bestimmen können wenn das auch uns
an käme also zufrieden gestellt was in
diesem mandat drin aber wir hätten sie
sich den eindruck hat dass kann ich
ihnen sehr gerne sagen also davon
abgesehen dass wir natürlich dafür
gesorgt hatten dass die ortskräfte
früher evakuiert wir hätten das wort ort
kräfte zum beispiel meine mandats
beschluss mit rein geschrieben wir
hätten deutlich gemacht wer dort alles
evakuiert wird und eben nicht nur leute
die erst nach 2013 für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet hätten um all das hat mir
deutlich gemacht wenn ihre
mitgliedschaft unsere stimmen angekommen
hätten dann hätten wir doch darauf genau
ich möchte noch einmal was sagen nur
dass die leute das zuhause verstehen
genau wir kennen doch alle noch dieses
grüne ringen beim kosovo krieg ich
errang die grünen mit ihrem gewissen
stimmen sie zu oder stimmen sie nicht zu
joschka fischer heute die beantwortung
bestehe was ganz anderes in dieser
fraktion gab es ja stimmenthaltung und
nein stimmen das ist nicht der alte
grüne gewissenskonflikt das ist einfach
kompletten chancen politische
orientierungslosigkeit kunst das hätten
sich die grünen nummer zwei ist
afghanistan mandat das letzte mal
verlängert wurde das waren 25 märz
dieses jahres hat es in der
grünen-bundestagsfraktion zustimmung
enthaltungen und nein giessen red
zudem afghanistan ja genau so und das
hat natürlich fragen sind die übrigens
in der häufig auf fraktion nicht
geschlossen abgestimmt haben also das
jetzt so darzustellen mal ganz ehrlich
jahrelang wurde der linken erzählt ihr
müsst eure außenpolitischen positionen
ändert ihr müsst auslandseinsätzen
zuschauern wird seit der nichtregierungs
weg jetzt nach 20 jahren gescheitert der
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan
derartig desaströse wir haben immer
davor gewarnt und jetzt sind wir
diejenigen die leute im stich lassen wir
haben doch auch immer davor gewarnt
deutschland dürfen nicht zu viele
flüchtlinge aufnehmen wie ich habe immer
nicht dafür eingesetzt ganz ehrlich und
ich habe mich immer für ein
abschiebestopp eingesetzt für die
aufnahme von afghanischer flüchtling war
dieses jahr
die bundeswehr die sind nicht schicken
mit den worten von rechten auf dem
vermutlich bringen bundes schlinge
die bundeswehr sieht man dort ihren
wollen fliegt in diesen maschinen wie
sie ja dass das rechtlich flüchtlinge
deswegen haben wir auch nicht dagegen
gestand deswegen enthalten weil wir
sagen ja zu der rettungsmission ja
leider ist so viel zeit verstrichen
worden dass man das vor ein paar monaten
hat man das ja mit zivilen flugzeugen
machen können mir ist froh dass es jetzt
einem eine abgesicherte luftbrücke baut
aber dieses mandat der bundeswehr
schauen sie sich an es ist ein beschluss
mandat was wirklich alles offen lassen
und was ein robustes mandat ist was die
einsatz von militärischer gewalt über
die selbstverteidigung hinaus zulässt es
ist überhaupt völlig unbestimmt das ist
in den mandaten die rede davon dass es
in absprache mit der afghanischen
regierung geschieht ja wer ist denn
gerade die afghanische regierung ashraf
ghani der im ausland ist ist dass die
taliban wer ist das denn gerade und
deswegen haben wir uns jemand als
beschluss angeschaut also machen daran
eine kritik und wir sagen ja
das ist doch das ist doch abend darüber
dass sie in einer ganz kurz die csu
werde ich von herrn söder verklage ich
das doch abenteuerlich was sie in den
letzten minuten präsentiert haben ich
sage mal ganz deutlich wir heute im
deutschen bundestag seine hand nicht
behoben hat für dieses mandat der hat
sich moralisch in dieser frage
diskreditiert hier am abend dann
irgendwo mitzureden hier im warmen
studie vom herrn lanz dann zu
theoretisieren was man alles retten
könnte aber gleichzeitig geben nicht die
hand zu reichen zu dem was notwendig ist
so kein ponyhof da ist nicht kinder
verschieden sein unter lebensgefahr sind
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz um die humanitäre aktionen zu
gewährleisten es kommt allerdings das
würde ich aber also sagen natürlich
nicht überraschend dass die linke heute
da nicht dabei denn sie sind ja denn sie
hatte standen ja noch nie in den letzten
20 jahren zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt
jemals einer seite unter soldatinnen und
soldaten egal wo die im einsatz waren
und was mich ehrlich gesagt noch viel
mehr bestürzt frau wissler dass sie bis
zum heutigen tage ständig aus ihrer
partei aus diesen sozialistischen
kommunistischen netzwerken von ihnen der
max21 und anderes irgendwelche
unterstützungsbekundungen für die
taliban höre da wird von ihnen sie
priesen ja dann nächstes mal nach da
wird von ihnen gepriesen dass die ein
tolles rechtssystem da etabliert haben
das erste mal dass ich höre dass die
scharia wirklich ein ganz tolles
gerechtes rechtssystem wäre und ich habe
bis zum heutigen zeitpunkt auch keine
klare distanzierung gehört wenn leute
sagen sie freuen sich dass die taliban
übernommen haben dass dann sogar sich
gefreut wird über tote
bundeswehrsoldaten im
schulhaus das stimmt
müssen wir ihnen hat sich gefreut dass
an seinen 69 die afghanen abgeschoben
wurden bis vor zwei wochen wollten die
menschen nach afghanistan abschieben und
jetzt erzählen sie und werfen uns vor
wir würden leute im stich lassen das ist
doch wirklich schlecht
es gebe sichere regionen in afghanistan
kurz vor menschen abschieben abschiebung
tschuldigung und ein bisschen was durch
seiner frau ist das ist nicht nur ganz
kurz
darüber reden begleichen und auch über
die frage ich find ja dass die ganze
geschichte der zwei teile die geschichte
der zwei teilen sich die frage ganz
grundsätzlich in afghanistan rein gehen
oder nicht mich auch sehr gespannt auf
ihre einlassungen und ich habe schon das
gefühl dass ihre position da über die
jahre hinweg die idee sozusagen
demokratie zu exportieren das hat nicht
funktioniert oder waren sie immun als
linkspartei über viele jahre hinweg das
will ich gerne konzentrieren aber noch
mal ganz kurz das was sie gerade
angesprochen haben hamburger wie santana
soli mitglied der linkspartei der
gepostet hat ich zitiere ich gratuliere
dem afghanischen volk zu ihre musik über
die ausländischen besatzer in klammern
insbesondere zu jedem einzelnen
der 37 von ihnen eliminierten
bundeswehrsoldaten linken mitglied
facebook post mittlerweile
parteiausschlussverfahren eingeleitet
korrekter weise wie kommt es zu solchen
einlassungen ich kenne ja auch andere
positionen aus ihrer partei ich frage
mich trotzdem warum gibt es immer wieder
solche unfassbar irakischen moment der
immer in ihrer partei
ich finde dass die aussage furchtbar wir
der landesverband hamburg hat sofort ein
ausschlussverfahren angestoßen ich kenne
selber sehr sehr viele afghanen afghanen
die familie in afghanistan noch haben
die sich riesige sorgen machen ich finde
das zynisch und natürlich freuen wir uns
über keinen toten bundeswehrsoldaten
gottes willen also wir haben immer
gesagt wir wollen natürlich die soldaten
dort rausholen um deren leben zu
schützen und die der zivilisten also
natürlich ist das eine furchtbare
kommentierung aber wie sehr hat
keinerlei funktion bei uns ne partei und
das gibt
und dass es irgendwann zweite ganz kurz
die leute verstehen damit die leute
verstehen sie hatten gerade ein robin
alexander hat sie bei den kollegen von
welt gestern konfrontiert mit einem
dokument von marx21 wo sie mitglied
waren es richtig gut die mitgliedschaft
und da sind sie da ganz raus
daraus okay aber ausgetreten aber sie
waren da mitglied ich war der
unterstützerinnen unterstützerin okay da
gibt es ein dokument
und das in diesem dokument steht
folgender satz oder soft folgen gesetze
entscheidend ist dass die taliban in den
von ihnen kontrollierten ländlichen
gebieten ein ehrliches justizsystem
betrieben haben ihr ruf ist so gut dass
sich viele menschen die in städten in
zivil prozesse verwickelt sind darauf
geeinigt haben dass beide parteien sich
an taliban richter auf dem lande wenden
dies ermöglicht dient eine schnelle
billige und faire rechtsprechung ohne
hohe bestechungsgelder da das urteil
gerecht war konnten beide parteien damit
leben wie finden sie das
teile des internets wie findet text
eingang eingang in so ein dokument sieht
fragen die das dokument erstellt haben
ich habe es nicht getan ich habe es
nicht gelesen woher soll ich das wissen
ich weiß nicht ob es ein interview eine
übersetzung ist also ich hab es nicht
eingestellt und es ist kein dokument der
partei die linke und für die
sprecherin wie bewerten sie das das
bewertet sich ja von selbst aber ich
würde sagen wir schalten jetzt nicht das
kind mit dem bade aus also die position
der linkspartei war der
afghanistan-einsatz ist falsch die
linkspartei er hat keine sympathien in
ihrer breite mit den taliban dass das
wäre wirklich unfälle deswegen leute am
rand und frau wissler stand eine zeit
lang für den rand jetzt sagt sie ja sie
ist da ausgetreten aber es gibt viele
also das gros der linkspartei hat keine
sympathien mit den taliban die
linkspartei hat immer gesagt der
afghanistaneinsatz ist falsch weil wir
da demokratie nicht exportieren können
heute interessanterweise hat denselben
punkt alexander gauland in seiner rede
gemacht aber es gibt jetzt zwei parteien
im deutschen bundestag die sagen
westliche werte sind nicht universell
und die kann man nicht überall
hinbringen aber jetzt ist nicht die
position dass die linkspartei den
taliban die daumen gedrückt hatte das
wäre glaube ich unfair